the best thing you can possibly do with
your life is tackle out of love
tiny beautiful things tells the story of
a brilliant but fledgling writer who is
offered to write an anonymous advice
column right as her life is falling
apart I'm a messed up woman my husband
kicked me out a few nights ago my
daughter hates me and I have no right to
give advice to anyone
when I first discovered Cheryl strade's
amazing book tiny beautiful things I
quickly realized that this is essential
human reading
it began with two people who wrote
letters to each other I'd never imagined
that it would even be a book let alone a
TV show the book was a series of
questions and answers we tried to have
the show really mirror that dear sugar
how do you decide whether or not to have
kids there will only be the choice you
make and the sure knowledge that any
choice will contain some loss
but it was always about finding no way
to bring all of Cheryl's letters as dear
sugar to life on screen in the series
I started building a story that had this
linear present and then this non-linear
past that almost plays like a memoir I
want to live my life and I think you
should live yours
one of the things that we wanted to
convey is this truth that all the things
that made us are always with us in the
present moment as you grow your point of
view changes your experience changes and
you change with it I think it's
important to Showcase slawed female
characters because that's what we all
are clerk come here I just came outside
and she was Frankie Ray are you drunk
well she made it home she's way smarter
than we ever were it's kind of a miracle
that we're alive really the flaws and
complexities of these characters is
really what makes them shine right now
who are you Claire I don't know
the show also explores humor and a lot
of hope I could
die you're not
life is full of suffering and difficult
things but laughter is right there with
the tears
our goal was to reflect a female
experience the experience of being a
mother the experience of being a
daughter life is about finding that
beautiful voice that's inside practicing
the word love so when it matters the
most you will say it
foreign
[Music]